so if you remember last week I made a
video called nine things you remember
wrong about Dragon Ball super and it got
a little controversial but I enjoyed the
discussions for the most part that took
place in the comments section the point
of the video I was trying to get across
was that there were more substantial
reasons to criticize Dragon Ball super
than the ones I pointed out in the video
many of you then criticized me for
saying that stating that I was an
apologist fanboy trying to cover my
bases and that totally isn't the reason
why I'm making this video totally doing
this for me just me I was going to do it
anyway so with that said here are five
bad things no one talks about in Dragon
Ball super that's right we're talking
about inconsistent character writing
real sexy [ __ ] hear people talk about
animation all the live long day but if
you ever mentioned the writing in a
specific way and the way Toa showcases
its characters is unapologetically poor
at times a couple of instances that I
found highlighted this best came during
the Future Trunks arc those cases being
Goku's juvenile portrayal be forgetting
how to greet someone for the tenth time
forgetting the Senzu beans screwing up
two people asked him in the battle kuku
isn't a complex character by design but
that doesn't mean he doesn't have any
complexity at all there is a nuanced
approach required when writing Goku's
character a deep understanding of what
his core motivations are and how he
perceives the world unfortunately there
are those in tow he's running staff that
have not demonstrated they understand
this boat amo Kaba head bro kale these
are all characters that were created for
Dragon Ball super but either did not
serve a purpose past their initial
unveiling or they were an overly
transparent cash grab through
merchandising I understand why
characters like Cobb on had exist and
were created but the issue I have with
them is that was their purpose for
creation had been fulfilled they just
sort of vanished or floundered cobble
was created to facilitate Vegeta's sense
a role once you get done that there
really wasn't anything left for him to
do the same goes for hit he fights Goku
a couple of times and now Goku is so far
ahead of him he too has become
inconsequential to the story not that he
had much of a presence to begin with and
regarding kale I have no issues with
merchandising specifically in Dragonball
but kales introduction is too
on-the-nose
it's as if TOA is saying hey look over
here it's that thing you guys like in my
last video I touched on the recap ARC's
discussing how they expanded on the
material from the movies however that
does not mean I thought that they did a
better job than the movies while I do
appreciate the effort to dive further
into the subjects explored I do not
think that the plot outlines for battle
of gods and resurrection F fit into a
Dragonball argh if that makes sense
compare them with the Namek saga or the
Kaku black arc and you will see clear
differences their placement seems odd
also we go from a battle of gods to
Fried's of trying to destroy the world
resurrection F just seems out of place
with really low stakes comparatively oh
and Dragon Ball super also suffers from
having way too many episodes centered
around a [ __ ] tournament when two of
the five arcs you have center around
tournaments and one of those two is 55
episodes long then you need to rethink
what the goal of your series is that's
not to say I didn't enjoy the universe
survival arc but I think there is
something to be said about variety in
the arcs wound rights for a series like
Dragon Ball and I'm someone who liked
the universe survival AK there are
plenty who rightfully didn't like it
because it was yet another tournament if
you look at Dragon Ball super as a whole
including the tournament of power there
are only two characters that stand out
as truly good villains those are as
imasu and Goku black and yes those are
both the same person
technically battle of gods had beerus
who isn't a villain Frieza is a
Dragonball Z villain it wasn't a villain
and literally everyone in the tournament
of power isn't a villain how could they
be if they are all battling for their
lives the original run of Dragon Ball
had iconic villains like piccolo Vegeta
and Frieza
characters whose motivations were clear
and had a presence this is something
that super sorely lacked in and I
honestly cannot wait for what the next
movie and potential continued series
might bring
Dragon Ball super is conclusions are
quite weak and what I mean by that is
how they tend to finish an arc the last
two arcs potentially three have all
finished around a table eating dinner
laughing I can understand the need to
give an audience closure with the Jing
Chi gosh that was a fun adventure I'm
happy we got out of that okay approach
but if you don't handle it gracefully it
can create an enormous disconnect with
the viewers from what they might have
just seen a mere episode prior the
Future Trunks arcs conclusion was
terrible to say the least and that's
being discussed by both geekdom and AJ
in the past I'd recommend checking out
both of their takes if you're interested
most of the people who watch my videos
are radish [ __ ] I absolutely love you
guys
it still blows me away that anyone cares
about anything I say and I really enjoy
reading your comments whether you agree
or disagree but nothing to me is worse
than certain members of this community
who only bring vitriol and hate to every
comments section they aimlessly wander
into I am NOT saying this to everyone
I'm saying this to the minority and I am
NOT talking about those that disagree
with me either
I never remove comments and I encourage
conversation beneath my videos I am
talking about those that offer nothing
constructive and only see red when it
comes to differing opinions on Dragon
Ball super these are the people who will
parrot the opinions of others who they
think are informed individuals stop this
I asked you not to agree with me but to
develop your own opinions based on the
facts that you know to be true and the
discussions you have with others to not
be afraid of being wrong I am wrong all
the time look at my videos and you'll
see an error here and there everywhere
especially in my older stuff huh but I
am NOT disappointed in myself for being
wrong that's how we learn these like the
last video are just my opinion on a
topic that has come to the forefront of
the Dragon Ball community lately one
that I thought needed addressing and one
I hope you were able to take something
away from if not I at least hope you
found my zany antics entertaining I
never intend to be mean-spirited in an
ironic way anyway and I hope you guys
picked up on that with that said I hope
you enjoyed this video subscribe for new
videos every week I love you guys and
I'll see you next week thank you so much
for watching